hi there
the video you're about to see is a bit
of a mixed bag i just wanted to say this
to warn you ahead of time uh it's a bit
more basic than other videos so i spend
a lot of time deriving back propagation
through time which is used for back
propagating through dynamical systems in
these papers
or in this paper and
also i spent quite a bit of time
explaining the reparameterization trick
and things of that nature and then after
that i go into three distinct examples
that they give in the paper that all
basically show the same thing so the
video is maybe a bit longer than it
needs to be especially if you're already
experienced feel free to skip ahead just
wanted to let you know um such that you
can
choose the parts that suit you
all right with that being said this is a
current research paper it is it's quite
cool what it shows it shows that you
might not always want to back propagate
through things even though you can
especially if they're
iterated systems especially if they're
noisy and chaotic
and they give some nice demonstrations
of when that's actually not appropriate
so yeah enjoy bye-bye
in summary
gradients are not all you need
just because you can take a gradient
doesn't mean you always should
that's how the paper ends now what paper
is this this is a paper called gradients
are not all you need and this is by luke
metz see daniel freeman samuel s
schonholtz and tal khachman
this is a paper that argues against in
certain cases against back propagating
through specifically dynamical systems
that can exhibit chaotic behavior so it
treats a bunch of applications of these
things
for example when people back propagate
through physics simulations when people
back propagate through inner learned
optimizers and so on and it shows that
very often in these cases it can happen
that the gradients you get
have extremely high variants are
extremely poorly behaved and so on and
that it might be better to just use
black box
black box estimators for these gradients
rather than actually back propagating
through the inner dynamical system this
might seem a little bit um this might
seem a little bit you know far-fetched
and out there but this is actually
happening people are back propagating
through all sorts of things nowadays as
i said physics simulations are now back
propagatable they're they're completely
differentiable you can back propagate
through a physics simulation and and get
a direct gradient and the same goes with
uh as i said learned optimizers so you
have an outer optimizer that learns an
inner optimizer and so on
all of this stuff becomes differentiable
and people are very excited about this
but this paper argues that as it says
you may not always want to do that and
this paper
goes into the details of why that is the
case
what can be done about it and where you
should pay attention
so they give a bunch of examples right
here of um
of these what they call dynamical
systems iterated dynamical systems that
you is are the basis for these
observations
so in a very basic case in a linear
iterated dynamic system
you have a state s and you apply a
matrix a k
and that will give you the next state
s k plus 1 right here
however if you do that over and over
again let's say you always have the same
matrix a and you just keep plugging in s
in here and get the next state so you
sort of plug it plug it into a it's a
recursive system or a recurrent system
one might call it you simply plug in the
same state over and over and over
or you put equivalently you put your
state through a neural network that has
always the same parameters to get the
next state and then you put that state
into the neural network and so on and
you might
get a loss function at some point this
should remind you for example of
something like reinforcement learning
where you have a state
s1
that
you put through some neural network f in
order to get the state s2 i'm sorry not
through a neural network of course
f in this case might be
the environment it might also be the
inner environment model of your
recurrent neural network it might also
be tracking the state so you might
always get an observation
you have an observation you derive a
state from it and that state is being
kept tracked by a neural network so many
things are possible right here
however let's say this is some sort of a
neural network that in some way
estimates these state transitions
then each state you can technically
derive a loss from maybe what kind of
reward did you get or something like
this so this gives you loss one this
gives you loss 2
this gives you loss 3
and this gives you loss 4.
that should be consistent in my
else
all of this together would obviously so
this would result in a total loss being
the sum of all the losses so
l i
and now the question is
if i now want to so every one of these
this neural network is always the same
there is a parameter vector that's part
of all of these neural network and now
i want to know how do i need to change
my neural network how do i need my to
change my estimator of this series
whatever that is a state transition in a
reinforcement learning problem for
example how do i need to change this
such that i do a better job at uh
predicting the future and therefore
minimizing all of these losses well
that's as easy as computing a gradient
a derivative sorry
obviously of my loss
with respect to
my parameters right
and
that's what
that's exactly what's happening right
here
uh so this should be familiar to you if
you ever have taken a class on recurrent
neural networks this is the chain rule
applied to neural networks sorry to
recurrent neural networks so what you
want to do is you can see the loss right
here
is
basically the path
to the loss is there are four paths to
the loss right here
so what you want to do is you want to
back propagate through all of the
possible paths uh that lead from the
parameter vector
into the loss it's a bit easier if you
just consider one of the losses let's
just consider l4 right here so what you
want to do is
you want to back propagate through this
node
through here here you encounter the
first parameter vector so that's one
term in your that's one piece in your
loss and then but you also want to back
propagate through this node right here
through it with the chain rule back
propagate through this path that's going
to be another one another piece of your
loss right here and so on you want to
back propagate through here up to here
and that's going to be another piece of
your loss
or of your of your uh derivative i
should say not of your loss of your
derivative of the loss l4 with respect
to the parameter vector similarly you
could do for the other losses so if i
did the same for l3 it would be
only here not to the right obviously
because
we we l3 does not depend on this
application right here so not that but
to here so that would be another part of
that gradient and through here that
would be another part of that gradient
so you'd get these sums of sums
and that's exactly what you have right
here all right if
the first step we simply back propagate
we use the chain rule to expand this
we back propagate to the step zero
and
uh from that to the parameters
plus maybe there's a direct influence on
the parameters
the first loss we have to take two
different paths okay so first through
the step one sorry state one
then back to state zero
which is if you can see that's the same
as this right here
so here
and here is the same
um and that means that these two paths
overlap right so if i look from we don't
have l0 here we have l1 so if i look
this path and the path that goes from
here back one state and then up here
those two paths partially overlap that's
exactly this
and then there is also this one right
here this would be the direct path
from here like
right up here
well okay i screwed this up a little bit
but you know
no one gets recurrent back propagation
right at the first try
in essence what you do get is you do get
these these big sums of derivatives and
what you can see that the components of
these sums as you go on so these are the
individual parts you can see here is the
general form for loss
t so little
lt
you can see that the individual parts
that get longer and longer right one
element two elements three elements four
elements
uh right here and the inside parts here
the inside is always we derive state two
with respect to state one then state one
with respect to state zero
and so on and the general form of this
is that
you start um
at a loss
and you go to its given state
then you go through the chain of states
all the way back
to state
to
you know state k where k goes from one
to t but in the worst case in the
longest case all the way to state
one i guess
that index is messed up right here right
i think so that should be like zero to
match up here
that should be zero
yes
excellent that should be zero good we we
made a difference we found a mistake
paper rejected go
no okay so the problem is obviously here
uh this is a single matrix right um if
and we're applying it over and over and
over again right we're we're deriving
from the uh we're driving through these
state transitions again and again and
again
and this can quickly get out of control
namely um so here by the way is the sum
of sums so this is the total the
derivative of the total loss is now a
sum of sums and inside each of these
sums uh you have these expanding
products these telescope products
i think they're called telescope
products not
exactly sure
they say note that this product here
appearing on the right hand side of
equation 8. the matrix of partial
derivatives that each state derived with
respect to the state right before it is
exactly the jacobian of the dynamical
system f that's the neural network
and this and so the neural network or
whatever that function is right defines
how one state goes to the next one so if
we back propagate through it we'll get
the first derivative of and that's a
jacobian if this is a
a high dimensional map
this has precisely the iterated
structure discussed in the beginning of
this section so the beginning of the
section we looked at what happens if we
just have a matrix we have a state and
the state that comes out we plug in
again
thus
one might not be surprised to find that
the gradients of loss functions of
dynamical systems depend intimately on
the spectra of jacobians
so what do they mean they mean that
this jacobian it has some sort of an
eigen spectrum and what we do care about
is notably the biggest eigenvalue so
this jacobian it
can be decomposed into
um
into
two transformations and a diagonal and
the diagonal is going to be
composed of the eigenvalues and the
largest eigenvalue here has a special
property
namely it determines uh sort of the
largest in absolute number so
let's let's just assume we only have
positive eigenvalues for the sake of
argument
if the largest eigenvalue here
is
larger than one then
the product whatever vector right
whatever vector i put in here for almost
all vectors if i put them through this
matrix and then put them in again and
then put them in again they're going to
grow in norm even if i do this enough
times then you just over time if you
look at the norm of whatever vector i
put in it's just going to grow
exponentially because every single time
it's going to be essentially multiplied
by a number greater than one at least in
in one component of the vector space
however if that is smaller than one then
the opposite happens namely whatever
vector i start with it's going to
essentially shrink
to
almost nothing
and
both of these are
problematic and in recurrent neural
networks you have heard them as two
problems so this problem here is called
the exploding
gradients problem
gradients and this here is called the
vanishing gradients problem
vanishing
gradients
and
the paper here makes the argument that
essentially the dynamical systems that
we're back propagating through it's not
only neural networks but also as i said
these simulations and so on they suffer
from the same fate right here and it it
it is even a bit um
let's say
a bit more pronounced and a bit more
hidden than it might be in recurring
neural networks
so they specifically talk about the
reparameterization
trick so what happens if we have such a
dynamical system and the dynamical
system also has some noise on it and one
of the
one good example of this is when you
apply the reparameterization trick
so what is that that is
when i have for example a variational
autoencoder variational autoencoder
takes something like an image right here
puts it through a neural network
into now if it was a regular auto
encoder it would put it into like a
latent vector
that's the encoder and then the decoder
would
reproduce the image from that latent
vector and the assumption here is that
if that if we train this well enough
this latent vector
will be a good description of what's in
the image it turns out that auto
encoders by themselves don't really work
no one knows
exactly why because it makes total sense
but might have something to do with the
loss function or
with them just being not super robust
however variational autoencoders work a
bit better and what they do is their
encoder notably does not produce a
vector like it doesn't produce the
latent representation by itself but what
it does is it produces the distribution
of the latent vectors
so what it does is it produces a whole
bunch of mu
and sigma parameters
essentially so mu and sigma mu and sigma
and they define the distributions of
each of the components of the
uh of the latent vector
so what we're saying is that all of the
la the latent vector is essentially
distributed like a gaussian and we are
not predicting the latent vector itself
we're predicting
the
parameters of the distribution
that describe the distribution of latent
vectors
so we're somehow inferring from the
image what the distribution of the
latent vector might be
and now in order to actually get an
image out of that we need to do this
step right here this sampling
sampling step
and that we can shove into our decoder
and then get an image out here
and all is good but now we have to train
the thing so how do we train we could do
the same thing we could apply a loss
like we do in the auto encoder compare
the output and the input and say these
two need to match
and you know we can do that
however
this is fine for the parameters of the
decoder the decoder has some parameters
we can back propagate this loss totally
to these parameters
the encoder also has some parameters and
then we run into the problem that we
need to back propagate through the
decoder and we need to back propagate
through this sampling step right here
which is not possible
now what do people do people have this
reparameterization trick where
essentially
if you look at this as a
parameterization graph i have the input
x here that goes through the um through
the encoder that gives me let's just
let's just say mu
and the sigma let's
write these as computation nodes
gives me a
mu
and a sigma
right here so the parameters are in in
these two arrows that we need to get
through and now the usual way of doing
of describing this is you you say we use
these two to get the distribution
and we use the distribution to sample
the latent code h and we use that to
produce
through the decoder to produce the
output and again we cannot back
propagate through this thing right here
so what do we do
otherwise
what we do
is
we say there is an interesting property
of gaussians some other distributions as
well but of gaussians specifically
namely that
there is this thing called a normal
distribution that has
mean 0 and standard deviation one and if
i sample a variable x according to that
um
and i imagine another distribution that
has
mu
and sigma arbitrary parameters not 0 and
1. sample y from that then x and y are
related by the fact that y is exactly x
times sigma plus mu this is sometimes
called a a z
transform
in statistics i believe or something
like this essentially what it says is
that i can sample from a distribution
with arbitrary parameters by first
sampling from a normal distribution and
simply multiplying
the output of that sample
by mu and sigma now that's interesting
because what we can now do we can change
our computation graph we can have our
sampling
our distribution right here
we can have our distribution that is a
normal distribution mu zero
sigma one
we can sample from that we can sample a
let's call it let's call it z just
because we can and then we can multiply
it by sigma and add mu right here we
multiply here we add and that gives us
that latent code and now you see
we don't have to back propagate through
sampling because sampling is down here
and our back propagation path can be
through here
this is called the reparameterization
trick
and this turns out to be it turns out to
be very good because we can train
variational auto encoders but it turns
out to be a bit of a deception when we
look at estimating gradients in these in
these systems so they make an analogy
right here and the problem by the way is
the paper says is that
if i have so my actual objective my
actual loss function here
has a sort of a smoothing in it right
because of this sampling step so this
sampling step
it it kind of smooths the loss function
right there is a certain uh
certain randomness in it and if i
average over the randomness then that
that gives the landscape a bit of a
smooth feeling however as you can see
the gradient flow is not the it is not
the smoothed variant the smoothing comes
is down here however the gradient flow
is straight through
all the deterministic route and that
might screw up your gradients big time
as far as i understand it i'm actually
not sure i understand this paper
correctly
they give an example right here where
they say
look we have a function right here that
we believe to be quite wonky which is
this sine wave
with a bit of a curve in it you see the
square function
those are these things here and they
change this w parameter so the higher
the w the more
squiggly the line is that's the
that's the
initial loss objective
and then they convolve
that
with
a
with a gaussian which gives them the
blue objective
now what they do is they say okay
can we use the reparameterization trick
to estimate the gradients and the point
here is that
i believe what the point is is that the
blue thing is the true objective right
the one that actually has the noisy
parts in it that is the true loss that's
the true objective you want to estimate
the gradient from
however your reparameterization trick
gradient it will be
it will be
along the
red function along the squiggly function
if that's not if i'm saying something
wrong i might be then i'm i'm really
sorry that's how i understand it
so
if
the oscillations are quite low then the
reparameterization tricks works super
well in fact it works about one or two
orders of magnitude better than if we
were to use a black box method to
estimate the gradient black box method
is i mean essentially
it's uh you have a you have a function
right you evaluated at two points like
here and here you draw the line you say
like the gradient is kind of like the
the uh
the the steepness of the line right
there you
it's not it's not that much more it's
just in higher dimensions
um
so
obviously reparameterization trick is
gonna work better because we can have
exact derivatives
however the more squiggly the line gets
the
more the noisy objective and the
objective where the re-parameterization
gradient flows are going to sort of
diverge from each other and as you can
see the re-parameterization
gradient is not it's not the case that
it's wrong it's just the case that its
variance is very high right so it's it's
not it's as far if i understand
correctly
the gradient is still let's say correct
it's it's uh unbiased
right
uh however its variance is going to be
super high if we
um
if we look at different samples if we
look at different places along maybe the
the x-axis it's going to be very very
very
high variance
instead the
re-permit sorry the black box gradient
it doesn't it doesn't really care it's
just going to estimate
pretty much the same um
with the same variance in all of the
issues and this is what the papers claim
ultimately is is that there are
situations where
back backpropagating through dynamic
systems is a good idea
and there are situations where backprop
back propagating through dynamic systems
is a bad idea uh because the gradients
have very high variance and you'd be
better off estimating the gradient
using some sort of a black box optimizer
so even though you could back propagate
through the system you're better off
just sort of estimating the gradient
by something like uh
what i just said right here or an es and
is it an evolutionary step i'm not
exactly sure
they dive into three different examples
so first
rigid body physics and here they say
they use a brax
which is a package that provides very
very fast physics simulations and on top
of that differentiable physics
simulations right excellent this is
really exciting because differentiating
through
uh physics simulations means that you
could technically optimize some stuff
really well
instead of doing reinforcement learning
you can now just look at you know which
action would actually bring my loss down
because i can factor in how the world
would react to my actions
uh in this case they say
um
we
yeah right so there is we look at policy
optimization of some stochastic policy
parameterized by neural network we test
this using the default and environment
and default multi-layer perceptron
policy so this is not a big
problem this is not a very complicated
problem
but it's enough to show this effect so
this is a stochastic policy
parameterized via a neural network which
means that
is this is you get the observation
this goes into a state
by a state encoder
this then goes through a neural network
that's going to give you
an action and a next state right and the
action is going to be stochastic if i
can um if i estimate this correctly so
it's give it's giving you an action
distribution like maybe this sometimes
this sometimes this sometimes this
action or
maybe it's a continuous actually i think
it's continuous and this probably
continues so it's going to give you some
sort of a distribution over actions and
to get the real action you actually need
to sample right
now does that sound familiar yes it
should right so this action this
so this is the action distribution let's
uh how do i make something into
distribution
a squiggly line double double
barrel thing
okay to get the real action you need to
sample and you push that into the
environment
and the environment's going to give you
a next observation and that together
with this state probably
maybe i don't know if this state gets in
or not it's going to to lead to state
two and then we start again right
the important part right here is that if
we back propagate through the
environment which we can do with brax
right
and we can also back propagate through
the stochastic policy
we could technically optimize this
neural network here directly to change
to the actions that actually give a much
much better outcome
however is this act does this actually
work in practice
so here is an experiment they do
so what they do is they
check um
[Music]
they do different unroll lengths
so they make a plot and say what if we
unroll this policy for one step for two
steps for four steps eight and sixteen
essentially means how many steps in the
environment are we gonna wait before we
do the back propagation you can't wait
for the whole episode that will blow
your memory
so usually these reinforcement learning
tasks even if they do if they don't back
propagate through the environment
they will stop after a number of steps
and then back propagate through that it
is a bit of a limited horizon so you
want to do as many as you can ideally in
order to get
really good improvements
so here you can see
different lines for different number of
on rolls the randomness is fixed so this
is always essentially starting from the
same state
and
what they plot here is mean loss
over these unrolls and what they plot
here is shift along a random direction
so
in this neural network
this here is a big vector of parameters
they take one of those parameters and
they just shift it a little bit they
just shift it a little bit as far as i
can understand
and they show what happens to the loss
as they do that right
now you can see if you consider one step
look ahead
it's still it's pretty smooth but still
like there is a lot of change in the
loss as you move this uh around
um yeah so then
and if you look at more and more and
more on rolls you can see that this
becomes more and more noisy the variance
as you shift along becomes heavier and
heavier and these systems become i think
the paper calls them chaotic which means
that a little change in the initial
condition will lead to a big change in
the sort of in the outcome
and that's
essentially their their problem right
here is that you can't really estimate
these gradients
through these dynamical systems because
just the variance of the gradients will
be
really really high
and they show right here what happens if
we don't just look at one on roll but we
do a bunch of unrolls right we take the
average over the randomness over the
unrolls and
as you can see that helps right you so
this is a fixed i believe this is um an
eight step on roll
so it's just from this eight step unroll
which is a reasonable look ahead they
take a bunch of them and they just
average over them and that gives you
a kind of a smoother line if you can see
right here so even if you take the
average over different samples if you
then unroll for more you can see that
still the gradient variance essentially
explodes this here is a log scale over
the mean gradient variance that's
essentially how many squiggles happen up
and down as you shift along these
directions and you can see that it's it
just kind of explodes
and that's uh the problem that the paper
wants to highlight
they go into two more examples right
here
one is a metal learning an optimizer so
that's when you have essentially an
outer
you have an outer
optimizers you have a big optimizer
optimizer big
that is that optimizes optimizer small
that optimizes a loss right so optimizer
small is doing its inner updates for a
neural network optimizing a loss and the
big optimizer is essentially optimizing
the parameters of
the
inner optimizer so you want to learn to
learn
and for that what you want to do is you
want to take this optimizer right here
run a bunch of these steps
here
see how much did you decrease the loss
and then learn the parameters of the
inner optimizer such that the loss is
decreased
more in future iterations it's a it's a
bit of an it's a bit of an alchemy field
i feel like this
i'm not i'm not so sure about um about
inner optimizers and so on but you can
you know you can back propagate through
the uh inner unrolling you can unroll
the inner optimizer you can back
propagate through all of it and
therefore you could learn the outer
optimizer like this
again you can see right here depending
on how long you unroll if you unroll for
just eight steps uh the the
system does not behave that chaotic you
can see that the lines is pretty flat as
you again shift a lot one parameter
along a given direction
however as soon as you go up to more
sort of reasonable things to unroll like
what actually people do in order to
learn something then you can see that
the system just behaves quite uh heavily
chaotic namely as you shift a little bit
the parameters change again you can
remedy that a little bit by averaging
this is an average over
doesn't even over are shown in color
okay we don't actually know which of
these lines we average over i think
i think it's one of the
like it's either the 512 or the 256 that
they average over
and it smooths down however still
as you can see right here depending on
the shift uh there can be situations
where the variance as you
unroll and this isn't even like this
isn't even for long right so
as the that the variance just explodes
right here
again this is a system with a bit of
randomness because the inner optimizer
is trained on mini batches and the mini
batches are sampled randomly right and
this randomness
comes external to the optimizer so the
optimizer the randomness essentially
enters from a different direction which
essentially gives the same artifact as
the reparameterization trick
the last example they go into is a
a not some sort of a deep learning thing
it's um
disk packing so this is like you have a
volume and you want to pack two
different sizes of discs so big discs
and small discs
and you you want to figure out like how
how should i pack the disks such that
they're packed the most and you can do
that via back propagation and they see
the same behavior right here that if
they sort of back propagate so you can
run
i think the simulation here and um you
can back propagate through it
and the result is essentially the same
is that um
there are
this is that diameter of the smaller
particle with respect to the larger
particle you can see that sometimes it's
well behaved however as you
get to
as you get to like regions where this
particle becomes rather small you unroll
for a number of steps this becomes very
unstable becomes very chaotic a small
change in the initial parameters leads
to a big change
in the end
result
and same thing right here if you unroll
for a number of steps the variance of
your gradients just becomes huge
and therefore
it's not really optimal to learn from it
so what does that all tell you they go
into different experiments right here so
they say
we go back to the first experiment of
the end and we look at the spectrum of
eigen values of that policy
and what they find is they compare
two different
runs
with two different initializations
init one is initialized in an unstable
regime so in one of these chaotic
regimes where they observe the gradients
exploding or the gradient variants
exploding
and in it too which is in a stable
regime and they wonder what's the
difference so they look at the spectrum
of the eigenvalues of the jacobians as
they back propagate and what they find
is that
in the one initialization the unstable
one you have quite a number of
of eigenvalues that have a norm larger
than one the eigenvalues can be
imaginary so everything outside the
circle is norm one
everything outside is larger you can see
right here
that
if they look at the the different steps
you can see that
after a while uh you can clearly see
that the maximum absolute eigenvalue
shoots up into
these are this is again a log scale and
if you look at the product of jacobians
right which is what you would do if you
actually unroll for a number of steps
then that product just grows
essentially every time it encounters one
of these big eigenvalues you just
pumps up it just grows in in norm so
this is again the the eigenvalue but
essentially
what you would multiply your loss or
your vectors by
and
again yeah so the gradient norms
correspondingly rise uh exactly with the
rise in the biggest eigenvalue of the
jacobian this is
like a straightforward consequence
so their conclusion is if
in the well-behaved behaved uh
initialization this doesn't happen
so so their conclusion is
look
if you can
if you can try to keep your
eigenvalues of your jacobians smaller
than one now that's easier said than
done so what can you actually do they
say pick well-behaved systems this isn't
that helpful because sometimes you
actually want to study these uh not so
well-behaved systems right
so for recurrent neural networks they
say there are
initializations that can help so there
is a
initialization
sorry they initialize the rnn near the
identity this means that the recurring
jacobian will have eigenvalues near one
and thus be able to be unrolled longer
before encountering issues however after
training progresses and weights update
the jacobian drifts eventually resulting
in vanishing or exploding gradients late
enough in training so this is not that
much of a
remedy they also suggest a
second solution is to change the problem
entirely the case of an rnn this is
feasible by simply changing the neural
architecture and i guess this is what
everyone learned at those classes on
recurrent neural networks is that things
like lstms and gru's they generally
avoid this problem
the current jacobian of an lstm was
specifically designed to avoid this
exponential sensitivity to the hidden
state because it has these gates and
additions and so on
and and
may i say residual connections
and is thus significantly more robust
than a vanilla rnn nevertheless it can
still happen right but with an lstm
you're sort of more protected
in rigid
body physics they talk about um
talk about maybe you have to go to a
complicated solution so instead of if
you have particles and they kind of bump
into each other
and bump into each other
maybe
you have to chunk up your simulation
into different parts so into this part
where you can back propagate through
then they're in a part where there's a
collision
and then once the collision happened you
can again
simulate forward and then back propagate
through that part and so on
so um
now i want to actually go down here jump
a little bit and discuss these two
sections right here truncated back
propagation and gradient clipping and
this is an idea that i guess everyone
has when you look at these results is
that can't we just kind of clip the
gradient or
like if the gradient's too big just kind
of tone it down a little bit in order to
not run into these issues right during
back propagation we might just you know
cap the gradient somewhere and then we
don't have these big gradients the
problem is that of course by doing that
you bias the gradient you it's no longer
the true gradient and they have for
example um done this in this brax
environment right here in this and task
and they say
in this task we back propagate the task
rewards directly to the policy
parameters after 400 steps for
truncation length t
ace sorry for truncation length tstop
gradient up was inserted every t steps
into the 400 step
trajectory
so they truncate the back propagation
through time
so they would
instead of back propagating through all
the sequence they would just chunk it
into like lengths of let's say three so
they introduce a stop gradient after
each three steps and that would
essentially make it such that the loss
from here can only go to here as i said
before
that is already happening when we unroll
for
sort of not as many steps because of
memory constraints but now we chunk even
smaller because we're afraid that the
gradient will explode even if we uh so
for the
length that we unroll
now what they find is that there is a
narrow band uh where this actually works
however um i guess i guess that's the
band right here where the reward is high
but
they essentially their their
their conclusion is that this disturbs
the gradients so much
that essentially
you
diminish your ability to learn anything
because the gradients are no longer good
unbiased gradients and i guess the same
goes with gradient clipping they said
if they tried the gradient clipping in
so as before this calculation of the
gradient is biased to demonstrate this
we took the same ant policy and sweep
learning rate and gradient clipping
strength i guess swept
or yeah we found no setting which
results in positive performance and thus
omitted the plot
right
zero
zero positive performance here
uh with gradient clipping in this very
simple environment that could actually
be optimized fairly easily and then also
reinforcement learning can optimize
fairly easily so here you can already
see the difference and the difference is
their fourth recommendation
just use black box gradients and by
black box gradients they essentially
mean you know these estimators that i've
shown you or for example reinforce which
is this uh
gradient estimator through black box
environments that is often used in
reinforcement learning reinforce gives
you an unbiased gradients
they also say in addition to the
unbiased methods there are other methods
and you might know them from
reinforcement learning for example
proximal policy optimization easily
outperforms all of our experiments uh
training the and policy with gradients
that we perform so the end policy with
gradients i guess
and there you have it this is a clear
this is at least one or three
demonstrations uh where
if you back propagate through the
environment even though you can
it is a more efficient to use a black
box let's say reinforcement learning
gradient estimator rather than the true
gradient because in chaotic systems
true gradients variances explodes
as you back propagate through long
sequences of these dynamical systems
and that's how
they reach their conclusions
they say
uh
we hope this paper shares light into
when gradients can be used namely when
the recurrent jacobian has small
eigenvalues in the other cases when
gradients do not work we encourage
readers to try black box methods they
estimate the same quantity and with less
pathological variance properties
especially when it's possible to
calculate a smooth proxy for the loss
function of interest
in summary gradients are not all you
need just because you can take a
gradient doesn't mean you always should
and that's the ending of this paper
um i know this was a bit of a
a bit of a all the way through uh
starting out from you know the
reparameterization trick and whatnot but
i hope you've seen the point that the
paper makes is that um
you know
things going more and more
differentiable can be dangerous
especially in the presence of chaotic
systems especially when there's a
component of stochasticity involved
you might want to think twice about
really back propagating through these
systems
because
it might just be as effective to use a
to use a good old black box optimizer
that was it let me know what you think
and i'll see you next time bye